there was this amazing uh friend of mine
your Charlie is um Iranian and he posted
the other day uh it was like a
juxtaposing what people think Iran looks
like versus a raw it looks like New York
City but what people think Iran looks
like it was like a you know just like a
box or something you know but it's
important to
have people thinking this way so you can
drive political objectives right you can
dehumanize
then you can just go Pummel the shit out
of him right I mean this happened when I
was touring in South Africa before I
left everyone was scared like don't go
oh my God this is gonna happen South
Africa it was like 2007 I think and they
were just like don't go this is so it's
so dangerous in South Africa and it got
in my head but it did I was like get out
of here you know I'll be fine and we
land I landed Joe Berg and with the
driver we pull up to the hotel I'm
getting out of the car to grab my
luggage and then all of a sudden
the
explosions like what the fuck even the
driver's like oh shit and we just get
under the car we're on the side
Breathing heavily
more explosions I was like oh shit they
were right they were so fucking right
and all of a sudden we hear caught all
right it was a great tank it was fucking
filming a movie downstairs I think it
was like Blood Diamond
filming down the street I was like oh
God damn they got me you know not the
the movie Incredible not the movie Shoot
but these bastards totally put this in
my head I bought into it and this is
embarrassing I fled War this is nothing
well yeah it's also like when people can
go there it's dangerous it's like where
a high school in America yeah exact high
school elementary school yeah it's
disgusting but that's what is south side
of Chicago
say that but I think it's important in
this time of like challenging what
you've been taught and what you've been
indoctrinated with it's like why do we
think that the you know that is more
dangerous than the school down the
street if we humans I guess we and this
is what I want to ask you before I let
you go is just like what you've learned
about human nature what we all have in
common in a good way and a bad way of
like we have this incredible ability to
tell ourselves stories that aren't true
we have this incredible ability to shoot
data that is not convenient for what our
narrative is of their bad we're good you
know Terror management Theory the Ernest
Becker book has really helped me with
that because I it helps me have
compassion for people that you're like
how could you believe this is true you
know like how could you think that how
could you go don't go to South Africa
man this would be really dangerous when
there's shootings in America you know
what how what do our brains
um why do they need to lie to themselves
it's catastrophizing yeah
that word changed my life really
it's a psychological term where you just
like project
things into the world where you think oh
my God I'm gonna be late uh to this
meeting everybody's gonna be waiting on
me I'm gonna be in so much trouble
everything's fucking you get there
you're the only person there yeah just
creating these scenarios in your mind
they're completely not true and then
somehow like preparing for the worst
preparing for the worst but you've had
the work you've that was you got that
honestly yes and it's like through that
experience has taught me to also
not catastrophe like hey man whatever
happens happens like what's written for
you is truly what's written for you like
I'm a prime example of that and I just
traveling the world I've been like about
50 countries and just seeing everybody
is the same everyone's struggling
everyone's trying to figure out their
way we're all floating on this ball in
the middle of space trying to figure
this shit out everybody has an issue at
home there's something even the ones
that are super happy they're bearing
something down people are the same just
speaking different languages but still
communicate in a in a really profound
way like I've talked to somebody that we
didn't even speak each other's language
at all but somehow communicate with each
other a woman no okay well yes I did
yeah yeah
no that happened that happened too but I
also like I did this thing in Durban
South Africa which is supposed to be
like one of the most dangerous cities in
South Africa was middle night I want to
go buy cigarettes and the security guard
is like don't go but I buy you the
cigarettes don't go I was like no I'm
good I wear the shirt long sleeve shirt
had Iman written in Arabic which means
faith
I put on a kufi which is like virtual so
you know like a Muslim uniform right now
I'm going out
and I'm gonna go buy stairs after 11
o'clock and I guess like please bro
don't go he's like begging me I was like
nah man I'm gonna go just leave me alone
I'll be fine
and I left
and I figured out really quickly it's
like I could see why he was telling me
not to go but I just went
and I was so well received like people
would say well the next thing you know I
was gone for like three hours ended up
hanging out with these guys on milk
crates in the slums like in a slummy
area not even the full slums but not
good
they were just smoking
the first time I've been uh introduced
to Durbin poison which is like a really
well-known weed
uh stream I just sat there and smoked
weed with them until I almost two
something in the morning
the security guard was mortified I come
back he's like brah and I'm high as shit
like just like bruh what you doing to me
bro you my responsibility huh
why you do this to me I was like what
relax man you're the only person that's
yelling at me yeah I was worried to come
home
he was just so blown away by it he was
just like wow I think he's like the
energy you put out is really important
that's it
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]